mein thema heute abend ist markus söder
der bayerische ministerpräsident fordert
jetzt wird es spannend konsequente
öffnung schritte söder schlägt vor zitat
mit einer ffp zwei maske können wir auf
den zweig regel im handel verzichten man
hält sich nur kurz in geschäften auf das
bayerische verwaltungsgericht hatte die
zweijährige einzelhandel kürzlich
gekippt für seine verhältnisse bei
markus söder trotzdem ein gewagter
vorstoß quasi von team vor sich zu team
mutig für mich schon jetzt der wahl des
jahres man möchte sie am liebsten
zurufen mensch markus geht doch
also ich bin ein bisschen überrascht
dass dir das schon reicht also ich meine
markus söder sagt masken müssen bleiben
das
2g abschaffen die jetzt schon reicht um
markus dazu sagen mensch ganz ganz toll
die wahrheit ist doch nur eine er hat
angst dass er seine wahl verliert und er
ist in panik geraten ja ich finde es
auch gut dass er sich so wandelt ein
bisschen ich habe es heute auch in die
richtung kommentiert bei b aber dennoch
muss man doch sagen wenn wir um uns
herum schauen und jetzt auf den nächsten
freedom day zum beispiel in schweden
schauen oder die entwicklung diese
norwegen dänemark und so weiter gibt
dann ist das ziemlich wenig paul und es
ist ja nicht so ganz über nacht gekommen
sondern markus söder ist natürlich
jemand der seine wechsel dies ja auch
schon mal häufiger gibt von dem ein
extrem ins andere doch klug intoniert
und vorbereitet und als teil einer
langen strategie darstellt er kann aus
dem weihnachtsurlaub und hat gesagt er
hat lange nachgedacht hat überlegt und
hat gesagt dass er etwas ändern muss man
natürlich gesehen hat gerade aus
oberbayern der gab es massiven druck
auch von seiner csu leute gesagt nur das
reicht uns jetzt alles und er muss einen
weg heraus finden aus dieser ja für
viele einschränkenden lage und deswegen
hatte diese neuen maßnahmen jetzt
präsentiert übrigens maßnahmen die in
anderen bundesländern wie niedersachsen
per gesicht per gericht schon nicht mehr
so sind und nicht mehr angewendet werden
also etwas in einen zustand überführt
was schon anderswo gilt aber man muss
natürlich auch mal sagen was wollen wir
denn für politiker die einfach erotisch
das durchziehen was sie einmal
angefangen haben oder darf man auch
dazulernen insofern ist ein instinkt
politiker wie söder immer natürlich
irgendwie auch mit einem rohr an der
masse und der wahlkampf ist schon
angesprochen worden man darf nicht
vergessen dass gerade die csu
eine ganz klare stammtisch partei ist
die kreisversammlung die ortsversammlung
fast alles findet an stammtischen statt
und wenn jetzt die wirtshäuser noch
länger zu bleiben mal abgesehen von der
gastronomie wirtschaft die auch arg
gebeutelten bayern dann hätte das
massive auswirkungen gerade auch auf die
mobilisierung an der csu-basis das darf
man auch nicht ganz vergessen also es
ist einerseits rational andererseits
kennen wir markus söder natürlich als
jemanden der so viele überzeugung hat
dass er sie nacheinander der
öffentlichkeit präsentieren muss also
gerade noch große fixe in den amtsstuben
aufgehängt dann bäume umarmt und
team vorsicht jetzt team mut ich also da
geht noch was also mensch markus kann
ich jetzt noch nicht unterstützen wir
warten wir erst mal noch mal ab ich bin
der festen überzeugung wir haben ganz
viele schlimme sachen gesehen wo wir
alle gedacht haben so das ist jetzt aber
schon über die grenze rüber von herrn
söder und ich möchte da nur daran
erinnern dass natürlich in gerade in
dieser corona zeit wo es um maßnahmen ja
oder nein geht da hat herr söder auch
teilweise marketingmaßnahmen gemacht die
ich sehr schlimm fand zum beispiel die
verlegung von 23 patienten aus rottal
inn oder aus der ecke da unten das ist
ja schon sehr kritisch wenn man das den
menschen zeigt die menschen kriegen
angst und jetzt auf einmal soll es
heißen keine angst mehr und ich muss
dazu sagen ich komme ja von den zahlen
und ich sehe diese dinge ja wenn 23
patienten verlegt werden auf
intensivstationen auch wenn es komisch
patienten sind so ist es doch so dass in
deutschland 194 1000 patienten auf
intensivstationen jedes jahr verlegt
werden in andere intensivstation also 23
werden mit presse begleitet weil sie
kobe patienten sind und was es mit den
anderen 194.000 ja aber wenn sie von den
zahlen her kommen ich wohne ja auch in
bayern und bayern ist es ja so dass die
ähnliche incidents werte hatten die
sachsen oder thüringen lange zeit und
jetzt immer noch der kreis mit den
meisten infektionen im moment und mit
den höchsten instanzen bis dahin ganz
deutschland also nahe münchen der
landkreis münchen führt ebersberg sind
alles führende
in dem sinne regionen und wir kommen ja
aus einer phase wo für uns diese zahlen
diese incident ziehen höchst bedrohlich
waren ich habe im vorletzten sommer eine
veranstaltung organisiert haben wir
absagen müssen weil die inzidenz zahl
bei drei lag jetzt liegt sie zum teil
über 2100 kann man sagen wie eure waren
wir damals aber das war natürlich die
situation
und deswegen bin ich da so ein bisschen
auch dem sinne soll das
erstaunlicherweise für verständnis zu
sagen das ist eine gewisse panik oder
aufgeregtheit gab und eben team vorsicht
angehalten aber es war nicht so dass ich
vor sicht sondern eben auch team panik
also hier nämlich wenn er in
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gesagt
haben gut gottes willen jeden tag den
wir hier leben stürzt ein flugzeug ab
und haben viele menschen sterben also
das habe ich dann schon als panikmache
ein bisschen empfunden und darüber
hinaus muss man sagen markus söder hat
seine politik eben sehr sehr spät jetzt
angepasst es gab ja schon länger die
analyse dass omikron eben nicht so
schlimm ist wie immer behauptet wurde
und dass eben weniger menschen in
intensivstationen sind und wenn ich mir
november/dezember anschaue wie markus so
dass ich dann noch geäußert hat da muss
ihm wohl irgendwie
die weihnachtsbeleuchtung gekommen seien
oder die neujahrs erleuchtung ich weiß
es nicht so viel anders als im dezember
sieht es nämlich eigentlich gar nicht
aus aber was mich noch viel mehr fuchs
ist die tatsache dass bayern riesen
incidence werte hatte und die begründung
ständig wechselten warum das so ist zum
teil wurde ist auf die grenze geschoben
wenn das die grenze gewesen wäre hätte
man die grenzen dicht machen müssen
jetzt gibt es neue studie sagt grenzen
dicht machen bringt gar nicht egal wenn
ich diese kausalität hersteller muss ich
dann auch so handeln nein die grenzen
betrieben wurden nicht aufmacht dann
hieß es wieder ja es sind die migranten
die vom balkan zurückkommen es gab mal
einen spektakulären fallen dingolfing im
bmw werk
das werk stand nahezu still weise auf
einen schlag glaube ich 500 leute mit
mit corona zurück kamen aber wir wissen
es bis heute nicht und was ist denn das
für ein wesen das wichtigste land in der
europäischen union und wir kriegen
einfach eine krankheit zumindest
wissentlich nicht durchdrungen
um die ursachen zu erforschen das wäre
mir einfach nicht in den kopf und ich
der datenschutz ist es die mangelnde
erhebung ist es einfach mentales
unvermögen sind wir zu bescheuert woran
liegt also ich würde sagen ist es dass
datenerhebung problem das wird ja auch
schon von vielen anderen professoren
professor anthes zum beispiel der hat
sich dazu ja schon vielfach geäußert ich
glaube auch professor steuer hat sich
dazu geäußert also ich kann ihnen nur
sagen wenn wir über incidents
entsprechen haben wir ein riesiges
problem weil instanzen haben nichts mit
erkrankungen zu tun ich will ihnen das
mal an einem beispiel veranschaulicht
erkenntnis die aber erst einmal nicht
von anfang an gegeben oder doch die
hätte sein können ja weil wir haben in
20 20 und 20 21 zum glück und das freut
mich auch dass wir die daten haben die
krankenhaus abrechnungsdaten für das
letzte quartal als 20 21 gekriegt und
man gibt dort einfach nur mal ein wie
viele leute von denen die als corona
hospitalisiert wurden als co wie kranke
hatten dann gar keine symptome das kann
man jetzt rausfinden 70.000 fans das ist
eine ihre zahl ist das heißt also wir
haben instanzen wir haben leute die ins
krankenhaus gehen also eine
hospitalisierung und das ergebnis daraus
ist wie alle denken das ist irre voll
und es ist gar nicht so es sind 70.000
die wir mit ganz einfachen codierungen
herausfinden weil die fälle werden hier
am ende wenn jemand dann raus ist oder
vielleicht den sieg da kommen wir einmal
das ist ja auch dass
der spieler aber mich interessiert noch
ein letztes mal zu herr söder reif und
pauli ab die mir auch beide oft erlebt
wie ist er denn jetzt so als ob also
stimmt meint dass er es jetzt ein
gesehen hat oder ist ja eigentlich so
ein wahlkämpfer der jetzt einfach merkt
der wind weht einfach wirklich anlass
ich muss den stimmen hinter hat einfach
ein wahnsinnig gutes gespür dafür was im
land abgeht was aus seiner eigenen basis
kommt was verkaufbar ist und was nicht
verkaufbar ist und natürlich hat er auch
ein stab von mitarbeitern die in
bezahlen aufbereiten und die zahlen mit
denen in der öffentlichkeit operiert
wird sind ja ausmaße gar nicht erst gar
nicht die das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen es ist auch ein ster hat
keine zahlen der weiß keine einzige zu
doch er weiß zum beispiel dass wenn der
anstieg nicht mehr ergänzen zb von der
fall wenn der anstieg oder von der
hospitalisierung wenn der sich nicht
erhöht das dann eigentlich schon ein
kipp punkt erreicht ist das heißt man
hat das wissen das ist da etwas abflacht
ob man dann politisch den schluss daraus
zieht jetzt auch schon zu öffnen oder ob
man sagt okay es läuft ganz gut die
werte umfrage bei umfragen sympathie
sind eigentlich ganz gut warten wir noch
ein bisschen das gefühl der leute ist
noch nicht so dass es entspannt ist dann
bedienen ich lieber das gefühl auch das
spielt immer mit einer rolle also wir
dürfen nicht uns vorstellen dass corona
ein wissenschaftliches objekt ist und
die politik plötzlich nicht mehr
politisch agiert das tut sich sehr wohl
na ja also es sind ja grundsatzfragen
weil sie ja gefragt haben der markus
söder und so weiter welche welche basis
hat da ist er jetzt irgendwie jemand der
ein guter player ist in dieser corona
frage und ich bin der meinung dass er
das nicht ist der spielt wie die anderen
ministerpräsidenten mit kann man
natürlich auch bei mir nachlesen will
ich jetzt gar nicht viel darüber
sprechen aber für mich ist das was ich
hier sehe
wissenschaftlich mit sicherheit nicht
begründbar von den zahlen her kann ich
das nicht sehen und wenn wir nur über
incidents reden dann müssen ja
eigentlich erstmal grundsatzfragen
geklärt werden
das sind so einfache fragen das macht ja
gar keiner mehr wenn wir uns gegenseitig
treffen und einer von uns hat das in
sich und er überträgt das symptomlos an
den anderen dann muss noch geklärt
werden kann der andere davon überhaupt
schwer krank werden das habe ich das
robert-koch-institut gefragt und
deswegen die wissen dass alle nicht und
dann hat das robert koch institut im
dezember 20 habe ich das gesamtwerk
darüber haben wir gar keine daten dann
hab ich noch mal im april 2021 gefragt
nach hause darüber haben wir immer noch
keine daten gestern hab ich noch mal
nachgefragt heute hat mir vor glasmacher
geantwortet es tut mir leid lesen wir
haben immer noch keine daten wir wissen
gar nicht ob jemand der einen anderen
symptomlos ansteckt ob er überhaupt bei
dem anderen die schwere krankheit
auslösen kann das wissen die nicht das
erheben die auch nicht schreiben sie
sogar unten noch drunter was wollen sie
denn da raus ich habe sich das ist
wichtig da wir uns jetzt nochmal ich
meinte sie ich man kriegt immer mit sehr
viel geht wenn man menschen wie ihm
widerspricht weil eine große community
natürlich ihnen folgt und an ihnen an
der glan doch und ihnen lippen hängt und
jede kritik an äußerungen dieser art
oder so ist immer im grunde ist diese
staffel 2 viele menschen ihnen glauben
schenkt und ist ja auch tausende neue
erkenntnisse nur politik agiert ja so
nicht politik kann nicht jedes mal wenn
sie sie hat ist gut wir wissen über die
lage in den gesundheits intensiven
darüber sicherlich berichtet es gibt zum
teil noch händisch ihre faxe ausfüllen
oder daten der absatz in der welt ein
bericht wieder händisch übertragen die
ihnen digital übermittelt worden sind so
ist die lage immer noch aber was folgt
daraus politik muss auf den moment
reagieren und ich war sehr froh sage ich
dass er tatsächlich da etwas offensiver
reagiert hat in der phase wo die
inzidenz hoch waren wo nicht klar war
wie sie sagen ob es diese übertragung
gibt und welche folgen das hat um dem
falle bin etwas nicht klar ist war ich
am anfang auch er für den offensiveren
kurs als zu sagen lass mal eben laufen